[Musique]
bonsoir patron je descends tout tu che
mais petit ami tu es bien pressé oui il
faut que je descende je ne les entend
pas ce n'est pas normal
vas-y fit nounours sitôt dit sitôt fait
le propos
attends je vais nettoyer mais
maintenant tu t'attendes pas bonne elle
donne deux minutes alors comme ça je ne
peux pas entrer non non non
je prend froid là dehors ça tu es très
gevrey bon puisque c'est comme ça mais
je remonte sur mon dieu
non jamais
qu'est-ce que vous fabriquez là dedans
vous avez sûrement fait des bêtises
[Musique]
je fais jamais de bêtises
je crois que tu peux à un très haut je
n'ai pas trop tout alors qu'est-ce qui
se passe
widy collant
à la salle des fêtes
avant d'aller au lit n'ose vous aimez
toilettes avant d'aller où l'humour
montre tes mains garnements
c'est du beau et là dessous
bravo à l'encrier renversé
au malin au lieu de le dire tout de
suite
[Musique]
non je ne dis pas ça arrive à tout le
monde de faire des tâches mais il faut
le dire tout de suite
on met tropez la nappe
une auto chambre haute a raison je vais
la mettre dans l'eau et demain elle sera
propre je te grande part nicolas mais va
vite te laver les mains avec beaucoup de
ce hameau
en soi
faisons frau
[Musique]
ce qui l'a gentil nounours ah oui ça y'a
bien scotché
mais la bonne nuit les pépins qu'on vous
ferez encore des bêtises vous le dirai
tout de suite c'est rami promis j'irais
là j'étale a eu lieu
à demain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nounours a tout à fait raison quand vous
faites une bêtise dit le tout de suite à
votre maman et elle vous grondera pan on
y va un patron en août bonne nuit les
enfants allez vite vous couchez effect 2
pour
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
oh